documentaries are [ __ ] they should be  illegal you should need like FDA  approval a license or something you have  to be licensed for it that's way more  dangerous than a gun don't let people do  documentaries give everybody a gun no  documentaries this happens all the time  when like people believe it have like  these Fringe ideas right it's like they  know so much about their Fringe idea  that you don't know so there's nothing  you can say you're right you can say  anything to me that you know more about  than me 911 and I can't push back I'm  not a structural engineering what am I  supposed to say no that's not what beams  are yeah right I might be onto something  exactly  you know if Candace put on 911  documentary I believe I believe in 911  yeah you don't believe in it now  honestly before nine it went 9 10 9 12.  no I believe in 9 11 100. so Candace  made me believe in numbers